Tom Hardy a phone and a car that's our
movie lock stars Tom Hardy and is
directed by Stephen Knight in this film
Tom Hardy plays a guy in a car with a
phone and a problem and that's our film
he has to drive to someplace which I
will not spoil for you because I find it
much more intriguing to be able to sit
down and watch this movie without
knowing what's going to happen without
understanding why he is so nervous
because as you watched the film play out
as he has these conversations on the
phone with people you begin to learn
what the problem is and once that is
apparent this film takes on a whole
nother level of Awesome because this
movie is incredibly well acted and very
well written this movie literally takes
place entirely in one car and it's only
Tom Hardy having phone conversations
with people sounds pretty boring right
well it's not it's actually pretty
freakin amazing I was riveted from scene
one in this movie largely because of Tom
Hardy's excellent oscar-worthy
performance his accent in this film is
sort of like this Welsh thing that he's
got going on but it's very very awesome
and you really start to understand why
he chose that accent because I watched
the Q&A that took place after I saw the
screening of his film with Tom Hardy and
one of the things he said was he wanted
to have an accent that gave his
character like this immensely calming
vibe because the large majority of the
film is him very nervous and very
anxious and he wanted to have the
contrast of sounding as if he was
actually very calm the entire time and
that was an amazing choice because
throughout this whole film you basically
are watching a man degrade you're
watching 90 minutes of a man's life go
from nice and peaceful to absolutely
chaotic and as you watch this
progression and you watch Tom Hardy's
progression as an actor transform
himself into this person it's
mesmerizing and when I learned about how
they shot it they basically shot the
film over a few nights they did the
entire film in a take or two and then
they would change the angle and do the
entire film again and they piece these
various scenes together that gives the
film a very in the moment feel it almost
feels as if you're watching
play and that's another really cool
strength about this movie is that it
does feel very realistic it doesn't feel
as if it's set up it doesn't feel faked
it all feels very much in the moment as
if you are watching real events take
place not just because of the acting but
the script because to have a film all in
one location to have it 80 to 90 minute
run time take place only inside a car
and only with conversations that script
has to be so so good and it was now I
can't see this movie being re watched
many times I don't think it has the
re-watch ability of other films that
take place all in one location such as
12 Angry Men which is one of the best if
not the best film that takes place all
in one location this film does not have
that rewatch ability but when you are in
the moment it is endlessly compelling I
found locked to be a very well-made film
with a terrific lead performance by Tom
Hardy a very awesome script and
characters on the phone that felt just
as real as he did despite the fact that
you never actually see them I don't want
to spoil what the problem is that he's
dealing with because when you watch the
film and you're able to experience it
for yourself in that way it'll be so
much more interesting to you than if I
had just told you right now I'm going to
give Locke and a - I think that it is a
very great film for the film it's trying
to be but I don't really think it has
the rewatch ability that it could have
if it expounded a little bit more upon
its location and use the claustrophobia
of the car slightly more to its benefit
guys if you see this movie and I
strongly suggest that you do let me know
what you thought of it below and as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck Benoist
so guys I want to let you know that my
audible promotion is still running that
is the promotion in which you guys can
get a free audiobook of your own through
me from audible as a thank you to you
guys for being so awesome if you like to
read as much as I do
and you're always on the go you can
download a book straight to your tablet
or your phone or to your computer you
can listen to it in your headphones on
an airplane on a bus on a train on your
bicycle while you're jog wherever you go
you can go to audible.com slash Chris
that's audible.com slash Chris and get a
free audio book of your choice I
downloaded Stephen King's carry they
also have his new doctor sleep book on
there and I find that so awesome because
he is my favorite author I strongly
suggest you guys checking that out
because it is a really cool thing
they're doing right now through me to be
able to give you guys that free audio
book it's totally free of charge and
it's my gift to you through audible
that's audible.com slash Kris thanks
guys